We're going to look at K-means as an optimization problem. So
remember when we talked about optimization we worried about configurations, I
think we called them inputs at that time but I think
it's going to be helpful to think of them as, as configurations
here. There was a way of scoring configurations and we were
trying to find configurations that had high score. And for some
of the algorithms we needed a notion of a neighborhood so
that we could move from configuration to configuration trying to improve.
>> Mm-hm.
>> So in this setting, the configuration, the thing
that we're optimizing over, is the partitions, the clusters,
and we also have this kind of auxiliary variable
of where the centers are for those clusters. And
what we need now is a notion of scores.
How do we score a particular clustering? So do
you have any thoughts about what would be a
better or worse clustering according to the kind of K-means algorithm?
>> Well, the thing about what you were
saying earlier, about what we were trying to do
with creating these clusters, and I look at
this notion of a center, so something pops in
my head. So, you would like to have centers or
partitions that somehow are good representations of your
data, and why does that matter? Because you
said in the very beginning that we often think
of unsupervised learning as compact representation. So if you
want to have a compact representation it would be nice
if you don't throw anything away. So, I'm going to say
that a good score will be something that captures just
how much error you introduce by representing these points as
partitions or in this case as centers. Does that make sense?
>> Okay. I guess that's a, that's a perfectly
reasonable way to think of it. I, another way to
think of it is in terms of error, right. Yeah,
which I guess is the same idea. Like if we're,
if you think about the object as being represented by the center of its cluster.
>> Mm-hm.
>> Then we want to know how far away from the center it is.
>> Right. And the farther away it is,
the more error you have in representing it.
>> Right. So, here is a concrete of writing down what we
think the scoring function could be. So we're going to say that the
error, it's kind of the negative score, right? This is something that
we want to minimize even though generally,
we've been talking about optimization as maximizing.
Here is something we want to minimize. That if you
give me a particular way of clustering it and
you define the centers based on, say, that cluster,
what we're going to do is we're going to
sum over all the objects the distance, the square distance actually, between
the object and its center. Right? So p of x is the
cluster for x and center sub that is the center for that cluster.
>> So that drives
home the idea that we're talking about Euclidean distance here because x would
have to be in the same space as the centers are by definition. Okay.
>> Yeah, and I'm not sure exactly how we're
going to define neighborhood. But one way to define
neighborhood is that the neighborhood of a configuration, which
is a p and a center is the set
of pairs where you keep the centers the same
and you change the partitions. Or you keep the
partitions the same and you move the centers. So
you're basically changing one of these at a time.
>> Oh, that's very clever, Michael.
>> Thanks.